on se souvient de cet accident tragique
c'est en avril 2014 matile de blaye tués
voyez sur son vélo et bien et depuis ce
moment à montréal on avait on avait
réfléchi à des manières de rendre plus
sécuritaire la pratique des du vélo pour
les cyclistes
or jacques bissonnet on est arrivé là
avec 26 propositions à l'hôtel de ville
de mourir oui parce que vous savez il ya
de plus en plus de cyclistes ans selon
la ville un adieu plus d'un adulte sur
deux à montréal utilisent le vélo pour
faire du transport que ce soit
occasionnel ou régulier donc c'est
important
alors pour tenter de régler tout ce
problème c'est parce que ça peut devenir
un problème
la ville propose pas moins de 26
recommandations alors en voici six parmi
les plus les principales finalement
recommandations alors la ville veut
interdire l'utilisation de téléphone de
baladeurs et des grands à vélo veut
permettre également aux sites les ce ne
pas s'arrêter aux panneaux ou d'arrière
à d'autres bourgs de ne pas faire leur
stop tout simplement comme on dit
communément on appelle ça le stop
américain de permettre aux cyclistes de
tourner à droite sur le feu rouge on
veut augmenter longuement le monde lié à
une infraction dans portier rage ce
néologisme en apport thiérache de
nouveaux moments où ça veut dire que
ouvrir sa portière de voiture pendant
qu'ils passent du site lilieslief risque
de rentrer dans la porte et a pu causer
des blessures sérieuses d'ailleurs il ya
eu mort là dessus d'ailleurs récemment
on veut aussi augmenter les amendes
visant les cyclistes mais on veut on
veut pas imposer un des points
d'inaptitude pour les cyclistes et une
dernière ne pas obliger le port du
casque du vélo pourquoi cette mesure là
pascal berthe on s'est rendu compte
qu'on a obligé le port du casque et on
s'est rendu compte qu'une baisse
d'utilisation de la bicyclette
marc évidemment c'est parce que la vie
se calmèrent kader chouette et on crée
aussi que ça devienne une situation
catastrophique pour bixi à montréal on
écoute la tue le maire est ainsi que
vélo québec
si on met des casques ou est-ce qu'on va
les retrouver ce que c'est votre cas
c'est ce que un moment donné tu oublies
ton castes les touristes force à la
question même d'hygiène et de santé
publique la balle serait posée que ces
points importants portent un casque faut
porter un casque
mais ce qu'on est obligé est ce qu'on
doit l'obliger il ya un espèce de
consensus social sur wii pour le port du
casque mais pas pour la loi
je pense que ce s'était vérifié à
plusieurs occasions dans les commissions
parlementaires dans les consultations
publiques et tous ceux à montréal ça
signifierait la mort de bixi gens qu'on
a vu ces publicités de la saq la ou les
automobiles et se fait ami avec le
cyclisme on veut de tout partout de
toutes parts un meilleur partage la
route quoi ouais le maire insiste sur la
route ou les rues à montréal
n'appartiennent pas uniquement aux
automobilistes les réflexes doivent
changer il doit y avoir une cohabitation
entre cyclistes et automobilistes
très bien merci jacques vous appris à
voir